even MSNBC has had to admit the caravan
isn't what the left spent weeks
portraying it as watch this admission
the the truth is the majority of the
people that are part of this Caravan
especially outside if we can make our
way all the way over there
will show you the majority of them are
men from what we've seen the majority
are actually men and some of these men
have not articulated that need for
asylum instead they have talked about
you know going to the United States for
a better life and to find work Enrique
Acevedo is an anchor at Univision and a
frequent and welcome guest on the show
and he joins us tonight Enrique thanks
very much for coming on so Ken now that
that it's here and the facts on the
ground are undeniable can we stop lying
and admit what is obviously true that
this Caravan is not primarily mothers
with children it's primarily men I find
it interesting talker that you're
criticizing journalist for presenting a
partial view of the carbon while you're
doing the exact same thing just from the
inspector for lying you're lying
together as a group reading the same
talking points from the Democratic
National Committee office script in
order to influence an election which is
what they were doing that's what I'm
accusing you of doing the caravan is not
a monolithic group talkers 8,000
different stories 8,000 different
realities and according to the
government's own numbers less than 10%
without any evidence but according to
those numbers less than 10 percents have
any criminal background so you're
talking about a group of 600 among more
than 8,000 people so 90% of them the
majority of them have a a legitimate
claim to request asylum
that's according to a but hold on oh
that's wait secretary for what they I
would say if 600 out of 8,000 are quote
known criminals that is a higher
percentage than a cross-section of the
American population so we're getting way
more criminals per per capita than we
know because they won't be just
90% this is what I'm talking this just
because you don't have a criminal record
does not mean you're eligible for asylum
so please address buck sexton's I
thought very incisive point that if you
are seeking asylum you are by definition
required to ask for it in the first safe
country you reach where you don't face a
mortal threat that was Mexico
where they were on the sound but that he
was being safe not in country where
thousands of people are being killed
every year actually more than you know
five hundred a thousand people have been
killed in Mexico in the last decade or
so so it's not a safe country it's my
second I knew you're gonna say that so
let me just ask you to follow up the
logical follow-up which is if Mexico is
so dangerous then you cannot seek asylum
there because you're imperiled just by
being in Mexico then why isn't the
entire population of Mexico eligible for
asylum in the United States well this is
the thing taco you see this immigrants
is Central American immigrants going
across Mexico they are victims of
extortion rape they have Brigham's of
murder and sometimes they're recruited
by these criminal gangs that's why in
part they're now moving across Mexico in
a large group because I know a great
country I get it I don't blame them what
I blame is the media which has been
lying relentlessly in an effort to
convince Americans of things that aren't
true so let me just ask you a pin you
down here know you've said that offer of
shelter Mexico said we will shelter you
will give you a sound sure they offered
that I think it's a criticism we insist
on putting this label on the caravan and
doing just why is the entire population
of Mexico since you said it's too
dangerous to live in why are they not
all eligible for asylum in the United
States since your question it's a
complicated question but I'm happy to
answer it it's there around there around
more than a hundred and thirty million
people in Mexico right now Ellen sees
focusing mainly boarding bordering
states with the US and in other parts of
the country so not the 130 million are
in peril but it is a dangerous country
and it is
you know but hold on since it's so
dangerous how many Mexicans just spit
ball for me are eligible under our
Asylum laws to come the United States
you should ask an immigration judge that
question and everyone should have the
chance to present the case everyone
there are the ones we're going to judge
the merits of an enemy of a asylum claim
and you know in this debate and in
absolutes and to understand that there
are nuances and there's context there's
no you're the one who told me it was all
women with kids and strollers let's
let's go back to the numbers the
official norms according to CBP the
majority of arrests today at the border
our family units so that's women and
children that's not an interpretation
but that doesn't mean the majority in
the Caribbean where Enrique I hope you
will come back it is always a pleasure
to talk to you thank you thanks for
having me